why hello there everyone i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
on march 1st
2022 and it's a big day because it is
joe
biden's state of the union address
tonight
that's right the elderly man pretending
to be president is going to get up there
and do his darndest to read off the
teleprompter and not screw up and not
talk about corn pop or his leg hair or
any of the other stuff and tell us how
great things are in america tell us that
we have defeated covet we will defeat
russia there's nothing that this man
can't do he's incredible that joe biden
and what we're going to be doing today
is uh recapping the last year or so of
the biden presidency and uh this is a i
would say a pretty
to biden a lot of people will be doing
responses and by the way we will be live
streaming tonight immediately after the
state of the union we're going to be
doing that with tequila
because how else would you do a response
to a joe biden speech um but this is my
pre-response because there's going to be
a lot of lying tonight right like this
is just going to be like an endless
cascade of lie after lie after lie after
lie and i thought it might be good if we
address some of that stuff before so
that when you're watching the thing
tonight
you'll be able to go well wait a minute
now some of that does not seem right
and i heard dave rubin
talk about it this morning so that is
what we're going to do and of course as
always do me a favor people would you
subscribe over on rumble would you
subscribe on youtube blaze all that good
stuff do me a solid would you all right
uh before we get to any of that though i
want to talk to you guys about cozy
earth you know one of the best things
about being filmed from the waist up is
that i can look like business up top
while being super comfy down below for
those of you who have been working from
home and participating in multiple zoom
meetings over the past year which may be
wrapping up because i think we defeated
kobit today uh you know exactly what i
mean that's why no gift will be more
appreciated by your loved ones than
cozier sheets pajamas or loungewear i
seriously love this stuff guys the
sweats are awesome they are so soft and
lightweight and that's because they are
made from super soft viscous from highly
sustainable bamboo
cozy earth's bedding and loungewear are
also temperature regulating so you'll
sleep comfortably year round it's no
wonder that cozy earth has become the
betting of choice for interior designers
and celebrities
cozy earth is so confident that you'll
love their products you can try anything
risk-free with their 100-night trial if
you don't love it return it within 100
days for free give the gift that'll be
appreciated every single night
especially if it's a gift to yourself
cozy earth bedding and loungewear and
now my audience can save 35 on cozy
earth bedding and loungewear just go to
cozyearth.com enter my promo code dave
and save 35 hurry that's 35 off at
cozyearth.com promo code dave goes the
earth.com and now back to me and you
could be wearing the same sweatpants as
me at night does it get any better than
that people okay let's talk about the
state of the union tonight this is when
once a year the president of the united
states gets up in front of a joint
session of congress and they read a
speech that someone else has written for
them where they in essence lay out what
has happened for the past year and their
future vision for the country now let me
just put the biases aside right up top
like i'm not really into this joe biden
guy right like i don't think he's a
particularly good president i did not
vote for the guy that being said i
didn't realize how badly it was going to
go and how quickly that would happen
but all of that being said and i really
do mean this i want the president to do
well
right like and any american should want
the president to do well meaning that
the guy is the pilot of the plane he's
the guy in charge he is the chief
executive of the government
and we are all citizens of this country
that he's purportedly in charge of and
you would want things to be going pretty
well so the economy is chugging along so
that you feel
safe and crime is low so that our
international relations are are sensible
and all of these things uh however
that's just not really been the case
with this guy uh and yesterday of course
they started announcing that we're gonna
wrap up the covet thing real quick we
touched on this at the top of the show
yesterday but i want to show it again
congress drops mass mandate ahead of
biden's state of the union speech on
tuesday mass square is now an individual
choice option the capital attending
physician said so just to be clear this
is what
most of us right-wing maniacs have been
calling for for about two years that you
would make a choice but these people
decided to mandate it to force companies
to force their employees
to put on masks or be vaccinated or
whatever it might be but suddenly in
time for the speech because they're
looking at the polls and we'll get to
the numbers in just a few minutes
they're realizing that they better back
out of all of this stuff so the very
same people
the very same democrats because it's
basically all democrats who are going to
be sitting in that chamber i assume
without masks tonight
um
still have kids in masks in schools in
new york and in california they're
rolling back that by the way too
but even in a place like california oops
now i owe somebody five bucks for the
get out of cali jar so we got to throw
that in there even in california some of
the cities are going to still keep the
mass mandates in related to the school
so
a week ago we all had to wear masks but
then science science science we're going
to have several hundred people sitting
in a chamber the most important people
in society these are politicians we
can't lose our politicians they are
going to be sitting there and it is
possible that someone in that room will
have covid a week ago they would have
been forced to wear a mask this time
they won't uh but of course and we did
show you this one yesterday again but i
just have to show it again just to
just to shine light on the fear
the fear that's all they got they got
fear man and you better just be fearful
of the fearful stuff that they're
throwing at you biden told us that a lot
of people were gonna die just in the
last two months it's here now and it's
spreading and it's going to increase
for unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and dead unvaccinated
for themselves their families and the
hospital they'll soon overwhelm but
there's good news if you're vaccinated
you have your booster shot you're
protected from severe illness and death
period
yeah it never happened we never got the
winter of severe illness or death we got
the winter of mild illness we got the
winter of pretty much everybody got
omicron and a lot of people got sick and
some people had leg pains for three days
and some people did get a little more
sick and of course some people died it's
part of life circle of life watch the
lion king sing the song you get it um
but he tried to paint that all as oh the
unvaccinated are the ones who are going
to end up overwhelming the hospitals
crashing the system somehow and we did a
lot of research on this phoenix you you
were doing some research on this this
morning we couldn't find any video of
any hospital that has collapsed under
the weight of kobe not anywhere in the
world we couldn't find one in africa
couldn't find one in europe couldn't
find one uh even in a southern state
here in the united states we couldn't
find any but they tried to use fear to
make us do what they wanted and then
finally because good people just
continued to live their life and fought
back in places like this florida that in
case you haven't heard i kind of dig
are led by guys like ron desantis well
then they started realizing holy cow
people don't like us and yada yada we're
wrapping this thing up for the state of
the union address tonight so we have a
whole slew over the next 25 minutes or
so of things that biden has said over
time and then sort of what happened in
reality before i get to any of that
though i want to talk to you guys about
battle box you know how are you going to
find your new favorite piece of outdoor
gear if you sign up for battle box
box with me right now uh it finds you
battle box is your go-to monthly
subscription for hand-picked outdoor
survival and everyday carry gear getting
the best gear for yourself not only
takes time but can be incredibly
expensive that's why battlebox brings
you name brand high quality products
every month at half the price of what
they'd cost on their own just pick the
box that works for you and get tested
and vetted products that you can trust
that are selected by an expert team of
outdoor professionals from an aquapod
emergency water kit to an atomic bear
survival bivvy delivered right to your
doorstep each month battlebox has
shipped over a million boxes since 2015
has been featured everywhere from the
new york times to survivor's edge david
loves to go camping and was excited to
find high quality binoculars and a knife
in our box which we got yesterday and we
are going to go camping somewhere in the
everglades personally i'm worried about
when the zombie apocalypse will strike
and whether or not we'll have enough
food in the house so i was thrilled to
receive battlelock's 72 hour emergency
meal kit find out why outdoor
enthusiasts call battlebox the best gear
i never knew i wanted sign up receive
survive what are you waiting for don't
miss another battle box mission and from
now until march 31st get a free mystery
box worth a hundred fifteen dollars or
more with any new subscription at
battlebox.com reuben that's a free
mystery box worth about 115 bucks right
now at tri battle box dot com slash
reuben try battle no t in there
battlebox.com reuben and now back to me
okay so let's just talk about joe
biden's record the guy has only been
president for a year it seems like a
lifetime i mean time you know in these
last two years of coven time has felt
very weird between lockdowns and people
staying at home and not going on
vacations all this stuff
it actually feels like the thread of
time has been like pushed and pulled in
very weird ways but joe biden has only
been president
for a little over a year it's about 13
months to be precise and things have not
gone very well for this elderly
gentleman pretending to be the president
of the united states uh ted cruz summed
it up nicely in a tweet uh let's pull
that up over there the state of the
union under president biden can be
summed up in one word crisis
inflation crisis
border crisis afghanistan crisis covid
crisis supply chain crisis ukraine
crisis
crime crisis okay so i thought that was
a good way
to frame the show today because he kind
of hit on a little bit of everything and
really nothing he said there is untrue
connor can we throw back to that for
just one second so i just want to show
people that what
cruz is saying here in essence like we
got an inflation problem you guys get it
we got a border problem right
afghanistan was a debacle kovid
apparently didn't go well until
yesterday uh supply chain we all know
about that i'm trying to buy a window
for downstairs they tell me i can't get
it for four months uh ukraine big
problem putin russia the whole shebang
and uh and crime as we've seen in
especially in our democrat-run cities so
cruz kind of framed the way that we're
gonna do the show today uh and we're
just gonna kind of dive into each one of
those issues and let's let's see we're
going to present you with some numbers
and
you decide whether things are going well
or not first off we've got some data
from real clear politics on biden's
approval ratings or i guess i should say
disapproval rating
which is up
13.8 points since he took office so as
you can see what you're looking at there
the red line that's constantly going up
that's disapproval so that's up about 14
points
and the approval which is the black line
you if you're the president you want
that one to go up that that's the one
that's going down and you can see
there's sort of a direct correlation
between the up and the down right there
that people are just not happy with this
guy now why would it be
that people are not happy
uh with this joe biden fellow well first
let's talk about the economy and
inflation we've got some data here from
the u.s inflation calculator the annual
inflation rate for the united states is
7.5
for the 12 months
ended in january 22
2022 the highest since february 1982 and
after rising 7
previously in 2021 according to u.s
labor department data published on
february 10th so in essence without
doing econ 101 when inflation goes up
the money that you have in your bank
account to buy whatever you want you
want to buy a car you want to buy a bed
you want to buy a playstation or a pen
that money is worth less so right now it
is worth about seven percent or seven
and a half percent less than it was and
by the way you know when they tell you
that inflation's around seven seven
point five percent which is which is
crazy like it's crazy crazy high when
they tell you that uh that means it's
probably
more than that right it just probably is
how the whole thing works so we all know
that our our the dollars that we've got
in our wallet
or what you've got in your paypal
account or your stripe account that
you're trading and going back and forth
on on zell or whatever payment thing you
use to to pay people for goods and
services we just know that that money is
not worth as much and you are now
getting less for it look at the price of
beef go to the supermarket
carton eggs milk etc etc we've got some
info here from powder and bulk solids
this is a manufacturing publication
talking about what's going on with the
supply chain and actually the nuts and
bolts of the economy america's
manufacturing industry shed
578 000 jobs in 2020 according to
federal data a report published this
year by deloitte and the manufacturing
institute forecasts that
2.1 million manufacturing positions
could be unfilled in the u.s by 2030.
shipping information company freightos
told reuters this august that the price
to ship one forty dollar container from
china to the east coast climbed more
than twenty thousand dollars an increase
of more than five hundred percent from
the previous year six and ten or sixty
percent of american consumers surveyed
by the pollster gallup said they were
unable to buy a product within the past
two months due to pandemic related
shortages of the sample 57 percent
reported that they experienced
significant delays when receiving a
product that they ordered the u.s census
bureau small business pulse survey
release
released in august found that 65
of small american manufacturing firms
experienced domestic supplier
interruptions during a sample period in
july 2021 a sizable portion of those
respondents about 40 percent said they
plan to find new supply chain options
over the coming
six months now you don't just need that
info to realize it you all know it
go literally anywhere go try to buy
anything we did this one day on the show
you may remember this a couple months
back on the show live i had not tested
it out before we did it i was i wanted
to we were looking into buying a couch
so i just picked three stores that you
might buy a couch from i think it was
creighton barrel cb2 in west elm if i'm
not mistaken and i just put in cb2 couch
creighton brow couch west elm couch and
each one this was back in like october
november
each one was you couldn't get it till
march of 2022 or april of 2022 or june
of 2022 go to any store and try to buy
any real
product go to your home depot see is it
stocked the way it was i can tell you as
someone that just moved and i'm here in
florida where desantis is doing the best
he can related to the supply chain and
things are moving a little bit better
here but he doesn't completely control
the borders and everything else like
even here things are tough to get go to
your target and see an awful lot of
empty shelves i was trying to buy a
freaking basketball at target they had
no basketballs okay like this is real
this is real stuff you all know it like
everyone knows it i can read you the
numbers but just think in your own life
when you're going to the store and
you're buying food are you paying more
money or less or is it the same
pretty much worse for everybody so okay
so that's one thing we know that the
economy
is just struggling and you almost don't
need me to explain it to you you just
know it uh well then cruz talked about
the border stuff and immigration uh so
first let's start with some video of our
southern border we don't talk about the
border anymore for some reason when that
orange man was president we were always
talking about the border and there was
going to be a wall and there was racists
and the whole freaking thing here's our
border in
september of 21 this is del rio texas
beneath this border bridge in del rio
texas a group of migrants grows by the
hour the men women and children mostly
from haiti tonight they number nearly 15
thousand tripling in size since
wednesday all waiting in near 100 degree
heat washing clothes in the rio grande
and sleeping outside for a chance to
claim asylum we need the administration
secretary mayor is the vice president
and the president to call this what it
is this is a crisis with staff unable to
keep up with processing state lawmakers
are calling on washington for help
first off people that was september of
2021 the peak of covid and i did not see
all of those people wearing masks and
the social distancing was not great to
say the least so i mean i'm joking about
it but that's like part of it right we
were supposedly in the midst of this
crazy pandemic and we're locking down
everybody and we're abusing these kids
in school and remote learning and all of
the stuff and meanwhile we've got quite
literally hundreds of thousands of
people pouring into our border there's
the video you just saw there and there's
obviously way more than that without
mass without social distancing we
weren't testing people we put them out
into the country sent them all over the
place etc etc um now the numbers believe
it or not
have gotten significantly worse i
suspect that you will believe it we've
got some data here from u.s customs and
border protection
the this is southwest land border
encounters over a year okay so in 2020
we had about 458 000 encounters now this
means you know someone's coming across
illegally they got caught they're
interrogated etcetera etcetera this
isn't exactly uh what they do with those
people at the time but in 2020
uh we had 458 000 of these interactions
that's when the orange man was president
in 2021
we had 1.734
million now i don't have my calculator
here but you guys can confirm this for
me uh that's significantly more it's
about 1.3
million more than the year before and
then and of course joe biden was
president in 2021 and then just in these
last few months the last four months
roughly october 2021 to january 2022
beginning of this year we've had 672
000 of these encounters now how many of
these people are here how many of these
people were arrested or sent back how
many of them have children that are now
here all the we don't really know but we
all kind of know something ain't right
but he's going to tell us tonight that
the border is more secure and he's going
to tell us that covet is over and all of
these things
and they're just not true now why would
he tell us all of these things one of
the reasons he would tell us all these
things is because we have a media that
does not question democrats as you know
nearly as intensely as they question
republicans uh now kamala harris is the
vice president uh
i suppose she's the vice president she's
this woman who apparently who seems to
me to be on drugs of some kind she's
constantly tackling uh and she just says
words she puts a lot of words together
doesn't really mean much uh but people
the media likes her even though she was
polling at zero percent when joe biden
selected her as vice president uh you
may remember this uh bizarre response
when she was asked about the border
crisis quickly put a button okay do you
have any plans to visit the border at
some point you know
we are going to the border we've been to
the border so this whole this whole this
whole thing about the border we've been
to the border we've been to the border
you haven't been to the border
i and i haven't been to europe
and i mean i don't know i don't
understand the point that you're making
i'm not discounting the importance of
the border well i i mentioned that
because
i know republicans have certainly come
at you on this but democratic
congressman cuellar has a border
district has said to the you and the
president come you can't see this listen
i care about what's happening at the
border i'm in guatemala
because
my focus is dealing with the root causes
of migration
there may be
uh
some who think that that is not
important
but it is my firm belief that if we care
about what's happening at the border we
better care about the root causes and
address them and so that's when
you've been to the border you've been to
the border well you haven't been to the
border
back into europe
i was going to go to italy
these people are just terrible and then
she gives this ridiculous answer like
i'm in guatemala dealing with the root
causes of why people are going it's like
oh well what'd you do lady what did you
do in the last five months in guatemala
that has stopped people from coming to
the border the answer ladles and jellies
bones is jack [ __ ] she did nothing
absolutely nothing uh we've got some
info from reuters here uh a little bit
more uh now going well let's shift
actually uh we i think we got the point
on the border uh let's talk about
afghanistan right so we we talked about
the economy we talked about immigration
then of course there was afghanistan now
you may remember of course this was in
august of 2021 i was off the grid when
this thing happened so i had to get
caught up pretty quickly when we did
that first show back in september with
adam corolla but this was a
absolutely
like
really a beyond
comprehendable destruction of foreign
policy now i was never for the afghan
war we were in war for 20 years it was
the longest war in american history
nobody really knew why we were there
anymore right it was just sort of going
on and on we're fighting the taliban
we're trying to disrupt al qaeda but
most of the people who did 9 11 were
from saudi arabia
something it seemed very weird
and so we all sort of wanted afghanistan
to wrap up i think but it did not wrap
up well and of course you guys all
remember some of this video
kabul airport this morning is back up
and running evacuation flights for u.s
embassy personnel and contractors in
full swing flights were stopped
yesterday when tens of thousands of
afghans stormed onto the runways
desperate to leave clinging onto
aircraft trying not to be left behind as
the americans pull out
u.s troops found themselves overwhelmed
as they tried to clear the airport
firing warning shots the pentagon says
american troops killed two armed afghans
but some afghans were able to get out on
one flight so full it may have set a
record for the number of people who can
fit onto an american c-17
afghans are running from the taliban now
in full control setting up checkpoints
with the very weapons american taxpayers
bought for the afghan army which
collapsed instead of fighting after the
u.s pulled out of bases and left them
without air support now doesn't that all
feel like a lifetime ago and it's sort
of like well why should we care anymore
we're gone
um but you know as we talk now about
what's going on with russia and ukraine
it's like what do people around the
world think the united states is all
about what do we do for our allies and
the people on the ground who are the
translators who are helping us fight the
taliban and everything else as they
reported right there the amount of
weapons we literally left hundreds
of millions of dollars of weapons and
tanks and helicopters and munitions and
all of these things that are now in the
hands of the people that we were
supposedly fighting
and the people that we betrayed on the
ground and again i'm not even saying we
were supposed to be there in the first
place and of course we had to wrap it up
but we we did it horrifically absolutely
horrifically and of course as you
remember and we've got some info from
reuters here i mean this was the sort of
worst of it as if those images of
afghans falling off the plane wasn't bad
enough
marines from the 2nd battalion 1st
marines regiment were on duty outside of
the kabul airport on august 26 when a
suicide bomber detonated explosives
killing at least 13 u.s service members
and scores of afghanistan of afghanis um
you know it's kind of interesting
because we don't know their names right
mainstream media didn't show you their
names these 13 people who signed up to
protect the united states who then died
due to a suicide bomber in a
horrifically botched escape from a
country that we're not totally sure why
we were in in the first place and the
reason i thought that afghanistan was
worth talking about is because obviously
foreign policy is on everyone's mind
tonight we're going to hear all sorts of
stuff tonight from biden about what's
going on with russia invading ukraine
and we showed you some video that
yesterday we've got a shorter version of
it today just to catch up this is the
russian invasion of ukraine which is
happening quite literally as we speak
is
[Music]
so look we'll see what biden says about
russia and ukraine you know yesterday we
showed you the video
of saki saying we have these incredibly
powerful sanctions and then uh one of
the american spokesmen saying no no our
sanctions don't do anything to russian
energy etc etc so
as i said yesterday it's extremely
difficult extremely difficult to figure
out what's really going on right there
unfortunately because everything is so
polarizing right now it's like if you
were to even just say hey let's just
let's just get going we got our own
problems i'd like to help the people of
ukraine usually when we try to help
people things get messy maybe we should
just be thinking about our own borders
and our own problems and everything else
they'll tell you you're a putin puppet
or some sort of isolationist or you're
probably a nazi you know that too so i
don't know exactly what we're supposed
to be doing there i do believe of course
that the people of ukraine have a right
to defend their homes and their homeland
this was an unprovoked attack by one
nation on another nation they're both
u.n members okay
so the charter of the u.n you can't
attack another u.n member um so we have
to figure out what to do and where the
united states fits in all of that um but
after you see what happened in
afghanistan only you know roughly eight
months ago and the disaster there it's
like do you think that this
administration led by this joe biden
who's going to give the speech tonight
do you think that that these people are
trustworthy or know what they're doing
or anything else i wonder what our
allies think i wonder what zylenski uh
the president of ukraine is thinking
right now like are the
are the united is the united states uh
trustworthy are they gonna help when
they say they're going to help et cetera
et cetera we'll see maybe biden's going
to lay out something really incredible
tonight i somehow doubt it but but we
will see uh so then of course what
really led us to everything related to
biden is all of the covet nonsense and i
would like to preface this all by saying
i live in the free state of florida i
was at a jam-packed event last night
with about 150 people smiling happy
refugees from all over the united states
coming here to live free in my
day-to-day life over the last two months
since i have moved to florida
covet basically has not existed i am not
saying covid does not exist i am not
saying that people don't get sick and
people don't die etc etc and i got
covered about six weeks ago i am just
saying maybe it was time to move on and
we wasted two years of our lives giving
power to people who did not deserve it
so we've got an image here from our
world in data on u.s coveted deaths and
cases per million and this is really
staggering you really have to look at
this so i want to i just want to make
sure everyone sees this because you know
if you've listened to the mainstream
media and paid attention to the way that
they've talked to us it seems like we've
just lost so many people all the time
and all of these things that we've done
have really helped and it's simply not
true so what you're seeing right there
the bump at the end of the the top uh
chart the top graph right there is that
basically
over sort of december january when it
gets really high that's when omicron
went crazy right and pretty much
everyone got coveted and then we started
getting herd immunity because we know
the vaccines were not working as
promised and now because so many people
got hurt immunity so many people got
coveted and mostly survived now the
numbers really are dumping out but look
where they're dumping out really just to
the levels that they were at roughly if
you look at that where they're at right
now at the end of that top chart the end
right there it's basically where the
numbers were around what is that let's
say march of uh last year but now we can
open up now we don't have to wear masks
now we don't need the mandates anymore
do you think this maybe has a little
something to do with politics those are
cases of course on the top level and
what you're seeing are deaths on the
bottom level and as you can see these
are k per million
so they peaked
in what's that about january of 2021
they peaked at 10 deaths
per million and right now they're at
about six deaths per million but somehow
all of the things that they told us we
had to do the vaccine mandates and the
masks and all this stuff we don't have
to do any of that anymore even though
the numbers are roughly the same and
that tells you this was always about
politics it just tells you that
obviously and they're looking at the
numbers they're looking at the numbers
and they're going we got midterms guys
they're coming up in a couple months
nobody really likes this old guy people
have had it with the masks and the
depression and the lockdowns and the
drug use and the ramp and crime that
came with all of this stuff and the
sort of cascading effects of society
collapsing under this nonsense and we
better do something about it quick and
as i mentioned last week when it was
starting to become obvious that they
were about to do this this turn on covet
right and you got to admire the evil not
the evil of what they do but the way
they do their evil you got to give the
devil his due it's like they are going
to have people believing by election
time in november that it was the
republicans who wanted to lock us down
and keep us in masks and all that stuff
that's what they do that's why it's like
kova just wrapped up and then bam we got
a war the script just changes i don't
know how the whole freaking thing works
i just don't know but i know that there
is something there related to all of
this so just to dive into the covid
numbers a little bit more we've got a
quote here from khn news uh this is uh
they are talking about tuesday the last
tuesday
of trump's presidency the death toll of
covid reached 400 000 people
a once unthinkable number so that was
the cumulative amount of people who had
died of kobit under donald trump 400 000
people as uh he hit the last day of his
presidency uh now we've got some info
here uh from the white house in february
of 2022
uh which today is march beginning of
march so this is just a couple days ago
today our nation marks another tragic
milestone
900 000 american lives have been lost
to covid19 so let's just say for just
one second that these numbers are
roughly right now we all know that they
were all the comorbidity stuff we know
that they're not taking into account age
and that you know if you came into the
hospital because you had a broken arm
that you also had covet and then
something happened like all of the
things that where they fudge numbers and
all that but what this means
okay is that 400 000 people
died under that scary orange man donald
trump from covid and 500 000 have died
in the year under joe biden joe biden
ran
saying that he was going to end
kovid right
here's some video of joe biden back in
october 2020 right before the election
220 000 americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
okay as always he muddled what he was
saying there but in essence at that
point there were 220 000 deaths there's
now been 500 000 under joe biden so by
his own words as muddled as they may be
i'm pretty sure he's saying that he
should step down so unless he's going to
step down tonight the guy's a hypocrite
but you know what you're going to do is
politician uh here's biden in january of
2021 this is just about a year ago
saying that he's going to shut down
the virus now you're president and
you're saying there's nothing we can do
to change the trajectory of the pandemic
in the next several months
what happened to two months ago when you
were talking declaratively about i am
going to shut down the virus well i'm
going to shut down the virus but not i
never said i'd do it in two months i
said it took a long time to get here
it's going to take a long time to beat
it
all right so to be clear he never shut
down the virus we're wrapping up the
virus and i'm i'm glad about that i'm
glad that i suppose in blue states
they're going to get to some level of
normalcy
that is good but as i just laid out it
has everything to do with politics and
virtually nothing to do with science
which is why i guarantee you i can ran t
u tonight when joe biden is going
through even if the biden campaign
people are watching this right now when
he's going through the numbers of the
amount of people that had covid say two
months ago and died of covid two months
ago versus the people today he's not
going to give you actual numbers on it
because the numbers won't indicate that
now it would be the time to get rid of
the mass and the thing and the vaccines
and all of that stuff like it just this
was all about politics that's exactly
what these people do so he he did not do
well and by the way you know i can be a
little glib about some of this stuff but
again it's not to diminish any of the
people that died of covid or any of the
people that have long coveted or are
suffering in any other way um this is
really about the people who were
supposed to be our trusted leaders over
the last two years who really became the
worst sort of totalitarian
uh
obsessive-controlling monsters over our
lives and there are some pockets of
america where they have very little
influence and that is a real beauty of
our federalist system let's move on from
covid though to crime
because you remember when donald trump
was present there were cities burning
and black lives matter in antifa and
we'd see things blowing up in the
background and cnn would be standing
there talking about mostly peaceful
protesters and we were defunding the
police because that made sense and all
that stuff what crime's rising too even
though now joe biden's president here's
some info from the council on criminal
justice drawing on crime data from a
sampling of 22 cities the study found
that the number of murders in 2021 was 5
higher than the counts recorded in 2020
representing 218 additional murders in
these cities and 44 greater than in 2019
representing about 1 300 additional
lives lost 16 of the 22 cities reported
a rise in homicide last year ranging
from increases of 108 in st petersburg
to less than one percent in memphis and
baltimore while six including seattle
and omaha saw a decline so we all know
this right like we know
whether it's murder whether it's petty
theft whether it's just walking into a
cvs or walgreens and putting your arm on
the counter with the big bag and
stealing all the stuff or walking into
louis vuitton or give me another fancy
store
bloomingdale's you michael uh that
people are just walking into stores and
stealing [ __ ] and people don't want to
stop them and you can't sort of blame
these people because especially if you
live in a blue city where the district
attorneys are not going to prosecute
people or you're going to then be
you know put on trial for trying to do
your job or god knows what or they've
defunded the police and the police have
had enough of the abuse we know that
crime is exploding everywhere i mean go
to one of these cities i don't recommend
it really but like send somebody you
don't like to new york or san francisco
or la and see what's going on and and
you all
just know it and that's directly related
by the way to this is my favorite chart
of the day
we've got some video here
about the california exodus and yes i'm
saying california so i'm going to throw
some money in the in the escape tally
fund and we're going to give it to
somebody at the end of the year who
wants to get the hell out of california
and move to florida but you can see this
is the estimated number of people
fleeing california and where they're
going
what's fascinating about this is i would
have thought that the uh that more
people the the circles that you're
seeing there uh that's where the
concentration of people are going i
would have thought more were ending up
in florida but that's you know that's
the 3 000 mile jump across the country
uh but most of the people are actually
ending up in texas and of course the the
question is are you going to vote the
right way
right so if you're a guy like joe rogan
it's like okay you were a bernie
supporter up in california when you live
there you got the 200 mill from spotify
you realize you didn't want to pay all
the taxes now you move to texas okay no
state income tax you're going to save a
lot of dough but are you going to make
sure
that you vote for republicans not
because you have to be a republican but
you can't be a democrat and you know
this is where i always talk about the
liberals you can't rail against woke-ism
rail against critical race theory all of
the big government programs that have
destroyed the places you live and then
you can't go
to the places that have done it right
and import those problems and and if
that's your plan then you should stay in
some of those places um anyway
i've got two more videos for you in
closing and this one came out yesterday
and it's like
they just lied they just lie they know
they're lying they know we know they're
lying and yet they continue to lie
here's joe biden claiming that
republicans are trying to stop black
people from voting yesterday we're going
to keep pushing on this and we're
protecting our country's threshold
liberty the sacred right to vote which
i've never seen is under such attack
you know it's always made it harder for
blacks to vote but this is trying to be
able to figure out how to keep the black
vote when it occurs from even counting
over the past year
we've directed federally
like the two morons in the back that
don't even know what they're applauding
i mean first off again biden is just
bumbling and mumbling and he doesn't
really say things in a proper way but
you sort of get the idea
that republicans are mean and they're
stopping black people from voting and
that's what they used to do and they're
doing it even worse now
not true do you know what republicans
are trying to do they're trying to make
sure that you have an id when you vote
and i guarantee you if you're watching
this you have some sport some form of
identification do you guys have uh i
don't i
yeah okay everyone in this room has
identification these aren't the
brightest people in the world okay
that's pretty good but i'm just saying
if these guys can do it you can do it
okay all right now i feel like i have to
get you guys guacamole today on the
chipotle after that that very intense
insult um everyone has id everyone has
id you need an id to get
on a plane you need an id to rent a golf
cart or whatever else you might be doing
so he's just lying and they just know
that they can lie over and over and
imply that the other people are racist
while they're really the racist
um and then i thought this would be the
perfect one to end on uh just yesterday
once again
dr jill biden and it's very important
that you refer to her as a doctor okay
which if anything she should be
examining joe which i guess she hasn't
gotten around to
um she was introducing uh kamala harris
and you're not gonna
take a look ladies
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the uni the vice president
[Applause]
i just said that to make you laugh
the vice president of the united states
scotland
why do they keep making this mistake joe
keeps making it dr jill keeps making it
everyone keeps making the same mistake
can we throw it up again i mean i just
have to with the audio
ladies and gentlemen
that's my husband there i think he's the
president but i'm gonna gentlemen
this idiot couldn't be in charge look at
him sitting there he doesn't know what
he's doing he's wearing a mask for no
[Applause]
just said that to reason you laugh i'm
hilarious my writers gave me this one
i've got 20 writers and they thought it
would be funny if i mistook the
president of the united states again
lordy lordy lordy anywho people that is
the official reuben report preview
of the state of the union things are not
great i wish that things were better i
really do
and i think we have to fight to make
things better and there are places where
things are better this place this state
where i i'm at right now is one of the
places where things are better um
but you're gonna get a whole load of
bunk tonight you're gonna get a bunch of
malarkey as joe would say and i thought
it was important to just reference some
of that so when you're watching this
with your
loved one your spouse
friend if you're having a big
state of the union party you're able to
say to them uh no you know a lot of that
stuff is nonsense and the economy was
better under trump and black
unemployment was at its all-time low and
hispanic unemployment was at its
all-time low and all of these things and
you know these guys are just liars uh a
couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com7
says uh my favorite flavor of pringles
isn't available biden has to go what's
your favorite you know
the sour cream and honey i haven't had a
pringle in a long long time and it seems
like a crazy thing to eat if you're over
the age of say 22. right you get out of
college maybe you should move on from
the pringles i'd like to know how old
you are seven uh but i had once i was at
sleepway camp my parents on visiting day
they brought a whole bunch of sour cream
and onion uh potato chips pringles and
then the counselors when the parents
left said you know you guys can't keep
all this candy all this food and i down
two
total containers of those things within
an hour
puked my brains out don't think i've had
pringles ever since this show is not
brought to you by pringles by the way uh
olaf says bummer i missed out on the
winter of death it would have been a
good miniseries right it's like listen
to what they were saying if you don't
get vaccinated you'll all die
we're taking the masks off for my little
talk amy says uh my daughter was
required to get vaxxed within 60 days of
employment she's a remote worker at her
company but she didn't and they finally
caved finally some wins yeah
finally some wins i have no doubt that
your daughter was making whatever
decision was best for her and was
thoughtful about it and everything else
and i do have to say you know two years
after all of this stuff it was my
personal choice not to get vaccinated i
was trying to pay attention to what was
going on and follow the narratives and
everything else and yes i did get covid
uh and there were moments where i got
pretty damn close to getting vaccinated
because i have you know family pressures
and and whatever it might be right and
and feeling like you know that the the
government is just gonna who knows what
like really who knows what sees bank
accounts would that be too crazy if you
didn't do what they wanted talk to our
friends up in canada um but i have to
say that two years after all of this i'm
very proud that i stuck to my guns and i
hope that as many of you as possible
stuck to your guns as well and i know
there are all sorts of pressureds you
don't want to be the family that takes
their kids out of school you don't want
to be the one guy at work who goes
against the trend and all that stuff
but i thought when we were kids we were
all told to stand up to the man say what
you think weren't those things like
don't follow the crowd weren't those
things that mattered that we were always
taught were the lessons of life right
like wasn't it that stuff
anyway let's see if joe biden offers us
anything uh positive about america talks
about individual rights talks about
freedom says the word liberty perhaps
talks about states rights uh talks about
ways that uh he could maybe lower taxes
let you have more of your money not let
you have more of your money let you keep
more of your money maybe you don't need
more of your money
but i suspect none of that's coming uh
as i said guys we will be live
immediately after the state of the union
tonight so if you have not do me a favor
and subscribe to our rumble channel our
youtube channel and of course you can
watch at the blaze as well uh part one
of my interview with harriet hageman
she is the republican running against
liz cheney in the uh wyoming
congressional race uh she is trying to
bring some conservative principals back
to wyoming obviously liz she's what i
call the pet republican that you know
these type of republicans that they
bring on msnbc to talk about how bad
republicans are and then they get pat on
the head and they get a cookie and it's
really wonderful liz you gotta go uh so
part one is up uh on youtube and rumble
right now and of course the full is up
absolutely ad free at
rubinportalogos.com
all right we've got a long day i'll see
you at about 10 roughly 10 p.m eastern
we'll see how long joe babel's force but
but i will be here
with tequila waiting for you
see you later